before she was playing the squeaky voed
bernardet on The Big Bang Theory Melissa
Roush was attending seminars on how to
get a job now she's co-writing movies
and executive producing TV shows but
rha's life has changed in even deeper
ways too prior to Landing her breakout
role on The Big Bang Theory Melissa Ral
was acting on a semi-regular basis but
they were all short-lived Parts she
played a minor part in the 2006 Steve
bumi film delirious and she appeared in
the short live series Kath and Kim Rous
told gold Derby that at the time of her
The Big Bang Theory audition is making a
living by guest starring on TV shows um
pretty much guest star work was my bread
and butter at the time naturally she
figured this latest gig would be the
same she told the outlet I was in
between some failed pilots and shows
that didn't get picked up and so I was
just excited to have a job for the week
Rous assumed that her appearance on a
season 3 episode would be like her past
jobs and that she would portray a
onetime character and then move on
however she couldn't have been more
wrong Big Bang Theory served as a ticket
out of her stressful guest star cycle
Rous knows firsthand how difficult it is
to make a state stable living as a guest
star in fact the week of her audition on
The Big Bang Theory she was at the
unemployment office collecting her check
she told The Hollywood Reporter I had to
go to the seminar about how to get a job
it was awful it was a dark week I
remember just being very nervous
thankfully she didn't have to worry
about her finances for much longer as
the relationship between bernardette and
Howard grew Rous was promoted from guest
star to series regular she would go on
to appear in 29 episodes of The Big Bang
Theory however despite being a series
regular Rous and fellow season 3 edition
miam B Alik weren't making nearly as
much as the original five cast members
while Jim Parsons Johnny glei Kaylee quo
Simon hellberg and Kunal ner were
racking in $1 million an episode Ral and
bik were earning
$200,000 when it came time to
renegotiate contracts for the final two
seasons Parsons and the others agreed to
decrease their per episode pay by
$100,000 this allowed Rous and biic to
get $450,000 an episode of course this
still didn't amount to equal pay but it
was more than enough for Rous to lip
comfortably on The Big Bang Theory the
squeaky voice that Roush uses for
burnadette as a major element of the
character it was us the whole time in
fact after hearing that voice come out
of Roush for an entire decade many
people believe the actor speaks that way
in real life however this isn't the case
and making bernardette her own Rous told
the Ruben report she Drew inspiration
from her mom Bernadette's voice is very
similar to my mother's um except without
the Jersey accent she often gets
recognized by fans while out and about
but when she speaks to them using her
normal voice they question whether or
not it's actually her then they'll hear
my voice and be like oh that's that's
not you ral's real voice also threw
Night Court audiences for a loop with
many taken to social media to express
their shock that the actor doesn't
actually sound like bernardet on the
social media platform X One user wrote
I'm so used to Melissa rash's
high-pitched burnadette voice after
years of struggling to land steady work
in Hollywood The Big Bang Theory helped
Roush make a name for herself even when
the show came to a Bittersweet end in
2019 Rous didn't have to wait long to
get involved with another successful
project on NBC's rebooted Night Court
ralh portrays Abby Stone daughter of the
late Harry Stone Abby is following in
his footsteps as the night Shi judge of
an arraignment Court in Manhattan a few
weeks after premiering in early 2023
Night Court proved to be a hit with
audiences as a result the show was
quickly renewed for a second season Rous
told collider of the show's early
success oh my goodness I'm endlessly
grateful I was really proud of
everything that we were doing and I was
personally really excited about it but
it just feels a bit like a dream come
true during the early days of Howard and
Bernadette's relationship on the Big
Bang the bernardet is extremely vocal
about the fact that she does not want
children she takes her career in
microbiology very seriously and she
fears that a baby would prevent her from
achieving her personal goals however
when she becomes pregnant with their
child bernardette has a different more
positive mindset about the whole thing
in fact it's Howard who freaks out about
the situation for Melissa Rous she was
an honor to Showcase a journey into
motherhood that's not often seen on
screen something she remains proud of to
this day through bernardet Rous let
women know that it's okay to favor
career Ambitions over having a baby she
also lets them know that it's okay for
them to change their mind she told Cafe
Mom I love that it just opened up the
conversation because as every human
being is different every mom is
different there's no one siiz fits all
motherhood Vibe we all feel since
becoming a series regular on The Big
Bang Theory Melissa Rous has established
the strong social media platform
including 2.4 million followers on
Instagram she's using that massive
following for Good by opening and
running Oscars kids a charity to support
the research of diffuse intrinsic
pontine Goma this is a rare form of
pediatric cancer that impacts everything
from breathing to the ability to speak
and eat it all started when Roush
received an Instagram message from the
mother of Oscar Kio a boy from Ireland
with the illness who was a massive fan
of the actor Rous befriended the family
and was heartbroken when Kio died at
only 5 years old she wanted to do
something and decided to launch the US
chapter of Oscar's kids Roush told
Forbes I feel like with having the
platform that I do and being so grateful
to have that it was Paramount to me that
I do something good with that and try
and make a difference when the Big Bang
Theory came to an end it was an
emotional time for the show's cast
members while this was certainly true
for Melissa Rous she found solace in the
fact that she had made meaningful
connections that would survive beyond
the sitcom while attending the series
rap party Rous spoke to Entertainment
Tonight about her feelings mainly I met
so many wonderful people here that will
be my friends for life Ral was
particularly excited about the
Friendship she formed with mayam biik as
she was a massive fan of bik's 90s
sitcom blossom in fact while being
interviewed on the podcast my MBI Alex
breakdown Rous revealed that she owned a
blossom as a child and often reenacted
the show's opening therefore when she
found herself sitting next to beik at a
table read she wondered if she should
reveal her fan girl status or play it
cool Ral said I was like do I bring it
up immediately or do I wait so that she
doesn't think I'm too thirsty even
before they were a couple Melissa and
her husband Winston Roush worked
together creatively it all started in
college during their freshman year when
they bonded over comedy and Penn some
sketches however they struggled to get
their work produced yet as Melissa honed
her comedic chops on the Big Bang Theory
and her platform grew she and Winston
were able to bring more of their
projects to life for example in 2015
their comedy film The Bronze was
released in addition to co-writing it
with Winston Melissa plays a former
gymnastics star who begrudgingly agrees
to train an upand cominging competitor
Melissa told Roger ebert.com the
experience of actually getting something
produced and being on set together was
so exciting more recently the Rouses
have been working together on the small
screen with both of them serving as
executive producers on the NBC reboot of
Night Court early on in her career while
living in New York City Rous tried to
make it as a comedian however this was
easier said than done she explained on
Late Night with Seth Meers how aspiring
standups have to pay their dues in the
Big Apple for her this involves standing
in Time Square and handing out flyers to
promote comedy shows Rous told Myers I
was standing outside a Broadway show and
I was trying to get people to come to
the late show and I was like come see
comedy come see comedy and this little
girl just looked at me and looked at her
mother and was like Mommy that's so sad
though she didn't break through as a
stand-up comedian The Big Bang Theory
helped Rous make it as a comedic actor
with many fans to the show haing her as
one of the funniest cast members on
Reddit one user wrote her sassy rude
character was hilarious throughout the
show yet she still had her Sweet Moments
with her friend/ husband meanwhile
another editor said lover Melissa Roush
is probably the most talented comedy
actor on the show with each passing year
social media is becoming more prevalent
in society especially among children and
teens due to the release of dopamine in
the brain it can become addictive for
users according to Jefferson Health
social media can have a big impact on
the brains of young people since adoles
is a major period of brain development
in May 2023 Melissa Rous became a
founding adviser of Gip media Savvy a
nonprofit launched by Julie shelfo and
Dr Heidi J B its mission is to promote
healthy technology use in young people
in an Instagram post that outlined the
goals of the nonprofits rash was candid
about how nervous she is about social
media's impact on the mental health of
adolescents she thanked shelfo and B for
not only taking a major step to address
the ever growing issue but also for
letting her be a part of the solution
the actor said their goal for get media
Savvy is to give people the tools to
fight media chaos and defend Humanity a
framework that empowers everyone to make
healthy media choices for kids as
Melissa Rous moves forward in her career
and accomplishes new Feats She'll always
look back at her time on The Big Bang
Theory with fondness after all the
series catapulted her into the spotlight
and led to her making lifelong friends
some of her favorite moments include
bernedette getting snippy with the child
audience at Howard's magic show and
Penny discovering Bernadette's ambition
to become Miss California Quiznos Rous
told today she had a particular fondness
for the qu no Episode by far one of the
most fun things I've ever done however
the thing she'll hold on to the
strongest is the evolution of bernardet
in the same interview Rous explained it
was cool to follow that Journey from her
not knowing if she even wanted kids to
not knowing if she'd be a good mom to
the struggle of when she finally did
become a mom and then just the very
relatable struggle of having to enter
back into the workplace after being home
and leaving her kids as an actor she
really enjoyed the raw emotion that
burned X Arc required and turned in some
of her strongest performances as a
result
[Music]